merci monsieur le ministre parle est un
monsieur patrick hetzel
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
par un simple décret du 5 décembre vous
venez de porter un coup très rude à
l'indépendance de la justice
les magistrats ont découvert avec
stupéfaction journal officiel que la
cour de cassation juridiction supérieure
de l'autorité judiciaire allait être
placée sous le contrôle du gouvernement
par l'intermédiaire de l'inspection
générale des services judiciaires alors
qu'auparavant ce contrôle se limiter aux
juridictions dit du premier et du second
degré
le décret du 5 décembre supprime cette
précision faisant de facto entre et la
cour de cassation dans le champ de
l'inspection générale c'est une rupture
totale avec la tradition républicaine
au point où fait extrêmement rare le
procureur général et le premier
président de la cour de cassation vous
ont adressé monsieur le premier ministre
un courrier pour obtenir des
explications jusqu'à présent la cour de
cassation effectué son contrôle elle
même par le biais d'un rapport
d'activité rendu tous les ans comme vous
le savez la cour de cassation à la
mission constitutionnelle de protéger
les libertés individuelles des
françaises et des français
elle ne doit en aucun cas être placée
sous le contrôle du pouvoir exécutif
de toute évidence ces décisions portent
clairement atteinte au principe de la
séparation des pouvoirs l'exécutif avoir
le contrôle direct sur la cour suprême
en france une nouvelle fois il y a un
écart béant entre vos discours et vos
actes monsieur le premier ministre
alors monsieur le premier ministre face
à la protestation légitime des plus
hauts magistrats de france
allez-vous d'une part les recevoir et
allez-vous évidemment revenir sur ce
funeste décret merci la parole est à
monsieur andré vallini secrétaire d'état
chargé des relations avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député jean jacques urvoas garde des
sceaux a reçu samedi dernier les deux
plus hauts magistrats de france pour
leur rappeler que le décret dont vous
parlez applique tout simplement à la
cour de cassation le régime appliqué
depuis des années à toutes les
juridictions judiciaires de france qui
sont soumises à des eaux
dites réalisées par des magistrats
indépendants c'est tout ce dont il
s'agit cette disposition a été renforcée
par la loi organique de 8 août 2016 et
la création de l'inspection générale de
la justice était une proposition de la
cour des comptes qui a été adopté à
l'unanimité
ici même dans cette assemblée la loi
organique de 8 août 2016 a non seulement
créé cette inspection mais elle a en
plus renforcé l'indépendance de ses
membres monsieur le député alain
notamment consacré explicitement leur
appartenance au corps judiciaire
avec toutes les garanties d'indépendance
et afférentes
il résulte bien sûr de la constitution
que l'inspection n'a pas compétence pour
se prononcer sur l'acte de juger sur les
jugements rendus évidemment cette
inspection s'inscrit donc tout
naturellement dans le respect de la
séparation des pouvoirs
et puisque vous parlez de grands écarts
monsieur le député je veux simplement
faire un peu d'historique sur la justice
depuis 2012 qui a suivi scrupuleusement
les avis du conseil supérieur la
magistrature ce gouvernement en matière
de nominations ce gouvernement
contrairement aux gouvernements
précédents qui qui a défendu la réforme
constitutionnelle de l'indépendance du
parquet ce gouvernement et cette
majorité contre votre opposition et
cette réforme n'a pas pu aller au bout à
cause de vous et enfin qui a fait
inscrire dans la loi l'interdiction
faite au ministre de la justice de
donner les instructions individuelles ce
gouvernement et cette majorité contre
votre position alors vous voyez monsieur
le député en matière d'indépendance de
la justice
il ya ceux qui en parlent et ceux qui la
respectent
merci monsieur le secrétaire d'état